I think it's time we got explicit about the
physical processes that lead to genetic variability and the physical
passing on of our genes. Now if you want to
have your own biological children, there's a pretty important event
that must precede the presence of children. instead of thinking
of you having your own children lets just think about
you, right. Here I am pretty happy, 30 years old.
But where did I come from? About 30 years ago,
I was in my mother's womb developing as an
embryo and then fetus. But where did I come from
before that? About nine months before I was born, I
was conceived meaning that the sex cells from my parents,
the sperm fertilized the egg and I received my
very first cell with a full genome. Half from mom,
half from dad. And of course about 30 minutes to
one full day before conception, there was a pretty important
physical interaction my biological mother and biological father
had to go through, the act of sexual intercourse.
For me to be here today, standing here, teaching
this course to you. All three of these previous
events must have happened. My parents must have found
each other and exchanged sex cells. They must have
had a successful fertilization of these sex cells. And
they must have had a successful development in utero,
or growing in my mother's womb. Now while I owe a lot to my mom and dad for
bringing me into this world, I really owe their
sex cells. Or what we call gametes. Gametes are
either sperm or eggs, sperm in male, eggs in
females. And germ cells make gametes. Germ cells are
the precursors to the sex cells. And in this
case the word germ. Doesn't mean germ like bacteria
it means germ like germination, like a flower.
The cells that make our gametes are called
germ cells because they are the seed for
our germination. So understanding how germ cells make
gamete is a really critical component to understanding
which alleles you're going to get from which parent.
Let's talk a little bit more about how
that process of cell division is going to occur.